WAS MAN EXPLAINING TO
CANADIANS THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT USE THE WORD MANKIND AND
THE U.S. SCHOOL AGREES.
WRITING GUIDE AT PURDUE
UNIVERSITY ACCREDITED SCHOOL
APPARENTLY TELLS STUDENTS TO
AVOID WORDS LIKE MAILMAN AND
MANKIND IN ORDER TO HAVE
NONSEXIST NON-BIASED
WRITING.
CATHY AREU IS FOUNDER AND
PUBLISHER OF CATALINA
MAGAZINE AND SHE THINK SHE
AGREES.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CATHY, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> HI, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Tucker: I HAVE GOT TO SAY
LECTURING US ABOUT SEXISM
WHILE YOU ARE SITTING RIGHT
NOW IN MANHATTAN.
>> MANHATTAN.
WE NEED TO RENAME THE CITY
THEN.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
>> THE BIG APPLE.
THE BIG APPLE WOULD BE LESS
OFFENSIVE.
I WOULD BE SITTING IN THE
APPLE NOT MANHATTAN.
>> Tucker: WHY SHOULD THE
POST OFFICE DELIVER MAIL.
>> IT'S M-A-I-L THAT'S OKAY.
IF IT'S M-A-L-E THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT SPELLING
IT'S GENDER INCLUSIVE.
MALE IS OFFENSIVE.
WE JUST LEARNED THAT.
>> I DON'T THINK THEY ARE
INCLUDING THAT BUT THEY ARE
SAYING THAT SOCIETY HAS
CHANGED AND TIMES ARE
CHANGING AND WE DON'T WANT
TO BE OFFENSIVE IN OUR
LANGUAGE.
AND THEY ARE TRYING
AND THEY ARE TRY TG
AND THEY ARE TRY TO BE
NONSEXIST AND NON-BIASED AND
THAT MEANS TRYING TO TAKE
THE WORD MAN OUT.
INSTEAD OF MAN MADE IT WOULD
BE SYNTHETIC.
INSTEAD OF MAILMAN IT WOULD
BE MAIL CARRIER.
THERE ARE MANY WAYS TO GO
AROUND IT INSTEAD OF
HUMANITY YOU SAY --
>> MAILMAN HAS MAIL IN IT?
>> M-A-I-L.
>> CAN YOU CHANGE A VOWEL
BUT IT SOUNDS THE SAME.
HAS THAT DREADED WORD THAT
SENDS PEOPLE SHRIEKING FOR
SAFE SPACE MALE.
>> THINK ARE SAYING MAN.
MAN IS THE WORD THAT THEY
ARE TRYING TO AVOID.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE
WORD MAN IS ASSOCIATED WITH
ADULT MEN AS OPPOSED TO JUST
HUMANITY OR HUMANS.
SO, THEY ARE TRYING TO AVOID
THE WORD MAN SO IF WE COULD
ELIMINATE THAT WORD, THEN
THINGS WOULD BE MUCH BETTER
AND PEOPLE WOULD BE LESS
ONGEGDED.
OFFENDED.
>> Tucker: WHAT IF YOU LIVED
IN MANCHESTER, VERMONT.
>> THEY MIGHT HAVE TO CHANGE
THE NAME OF THE CITY IF
PEOPLE AGREE WITH PURDUE
UNIVERSITY.
AND PURDUE UNIVERSITY FOUND
THAT THINGS NEED TO BE
UPDATED AND THEY UPDATED
THEIR WRITING GUIDE TO TAKE
OUT THESE WORDS THAT
APPARENTLY ARE OFFENDING
CERTAIN GROUPS OF PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO, OKAY, JUST TO
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THE
RULE.
IF SOMETHING OFFENDS
SOMEBODY, EVEN IF YOU HAVE
NEVER MET THAT PERSON,
PERSONALLY.
>> RIGHT.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO
CHANGE IT.
SO DOESN'T THAT MEAN THAT A
SMALL GROUP OF SUPER UNHAPPY
PEOPLE GET TO CONTROL WHAT
THE REST OF US SAY AND
THINK?
>> PERHAPS THEY ARE AHEAD OF
THEIR TIME.
MAYBE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS OFFENDING A SMALL GROUP
BUT THE GROUP IS GOING TO
GET LARGER AND TIMES ARE
CHANGING.
AND OUR LANGUAGE IS DYNAMIC.
WEBSTER KEEPS ADDING NEW
WORDS IN THE DICTIONARY.
SO OUR LANGUAGE NEEDS TO
CHANGE.
AND A TERM THAT USED TO BE
NON-OFFENSIVE LIKE MAN MADE
AND MAILMAN NEEDS TO BE
CHANGED.
>> Tucker: I GET THAT I
GUESS THE QUESTION FOR ME IS
WHO GUESS TO DECIDE WHAT
CHANGES AND WHAT DOESN'T?
FOR EXAMPLE I THINK I HAVE
NOW DECIDED THE MOST
OFFENSIVE WORD IN THE
LANGUAGE IS COLLEGE
PROFESSOR.
BECAUSE TO ME THAT CAN A
NOTES DUMBNESS AND MISUSE OF
POWER AND TENURE.
RIGHT ANDED ME 00 CREDIT AT
THIS SO MAYBE
EDIS SO MAYBE
ANIS SO MAYBE
ANDS SO MAYBE
AND MSO MAYBE
AND MED MAYBE
AND MEDIOAYBE
AND MEDIOCRBE
AND MEDIOCRITY.COULD I PULL THAT
AND MEDIOCRITY.COULD I PULL THAO
AND MEDIOCRITY.COULD I PULL THAF
AND MEDIOCRITY.COULD I PULL THA?
>> IF YOU HAVE A WRITING
GUIDE PERHAPS AND YOU PUT
THAT OUT THERE AND PEOPLE
AGREE WITH YOU THEN, YEAH,
MAYBE, MAYBE THAT BOO
MAYBE, MAYBE THAT WOO
MAYBE, MAYBE THAT WOULD FLY.
THE UNIVERSITY BACKED THEM
THEY HAVE A WRITING GUIDE
THAT NOW IS GOING TO TEACH
US HOW TO NOT OFFEND.
>> Tucker: BUT DO YOU THINK
THEY I HAVE THE GUTS, I
MEAN, IT'S ONE THING TO
BULLY THE LITTLE RICH KIDS
WHO GO TO YOUR SCHOOL
BECAUSE LIKE WHAT DO THEY
KNOW?
>> THIS IS INDIANA.
THIS IS THE HEART OF
AMERICA.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
IF YOU ARE PAYING LIKE 60
GRAND OR WHATEVER IT IS FOR
LIKE THE FAKE DIPLOMA YOU
GET, YOU KNOW, AND YOU ARE
NOT WORKING, OBVIOUSLY YOU
HAVE PRIVILEGE BY
DEFINITION.
NO MATTER WHO IS PAYING FOR
IT.
>> OKAY.
>> Tucker: EASY TO BOSS THEM
AROUND.
DO YOU THINK THEY WOULD HAVE
THE GUTS TO GO TO GOLDMAN
SACHS IN NEW YORK AND SAY
CHANGE YOUR NAME NOW OR
ELSE?
>> THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T
SHOP THERE.
THEY PROBABLY WOULDN'T SHOP
THERE.
>> Tucker: WHAT IF HE WERE
SHOPPING AT GOLDMAN SACHS.
WILL.
>> THE NAME MAN IS ADULT
MALE AND WE NEED TO CHANGE
IT LIKE WO-MAN HAS THE WORD
MAN IN THERE.
JUST CALL US A PERSON.
>> Tucker: SO GOLD PERSON
SAX?
WOULD THAT BE BETTER.
>> I THINK.
SO I'M LESS OFFENDED, YES.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, WHAT
IF YOU JUST -- SINCE THE
RULE IS IF YOU SPELL IT AND
I WILL STOP WITH THIS
BECAUSE I KNOW THIS IS
ANGELS ON THE HEAD OF A
PENDANT.
IF YOU SPELLED MAN
DIFFERENTLY LIKE MAA SO IT'S
LIKE MAILMAN BUT MAAN.
>> PROFESSIONS MALE
DOMINATED BUT THEY CHANGED.
SPELLING MAILMAN DIFFERENTLY
DOESN'T APPLY.
PROFESSION NOW APPLIES FOR
MEN AND WOMEN OR PERSONS.
ALL PEOPLE.
NO MAN NEEDED.
IN THE WORLD WOMAN.
>> CALL ME A PERSON.
I WOULD BE LESS OFFENDED.
NO NEED FOR WOMAN.
YEAH.
>> Tucker: IN THE END THE
REVOLUTION OFTEN EATS